[Musica]
benvenuto il nuovo episodio dello show
con karim usa sapete qual è il miglior
lavoro che potreste mai fare nell'ultimo
periodo diventare famosi eh sì perché
più si famoso più la gente chi regala
roba ti chiedono di partecipare a
interviste a programmi fa i film ei
libri e più sei famose più soldi ti
lanciano e più soldi ai più sei famoso e
più forniti lanciano è il miglior
trampolino di lancio ovviamente e
youtube tutte le più grandi star dodge
hanno iniziato su youtube
basti pensare a justin bieber che
suonava dalla sua cameretta ed è stato
scoperto o tanto famosi come uno
qualsiasi degli youtuber che seguite o
famosi tanto quanto la signora del
pellicciotto non so se l'avete visto il
video di questa signora che si incazza
con i commessi di un negozio e finisce
con lei che sviene a corpo morto per
terra ecco questo video ha girato
talmente tanto che questa signora prima
è andata da barbara d'urso e adesso fa
le serate dove potremmo scoprire tutta
la verità e io credo che sotto questo
livello di popolarità ci sia soltanto la
morte è quindi non vi piacerebbe
diventare famosi come la signora del
pellicciotto ma come fare caricare i
video su youtube perché il cazzo ve li
guarda e ci sono solo due modi per
rendere popolari video o lo fai bello o
ti compri le visual sempre più spesso mi
capita di beccare tra i correlati ma
anche in tendenza è capitato dei video
che hanno delle statistiche un po
sballate video che hanno troppe visual
rispetto e mi piace troppe viso a
rispetto ai commenti o troppi commenti
rispetto ai mi piace c'è da dire che a
volte youtube sbarella e questi numeri
vengono sballati anche da soli senza che
tu possa toccare niente ma la maggior
parte delle volte in realtà si tratta di
visual comprate online comprati o
commenti comprate e siccome una volta
l'anno mi sale il dark angel kraft
ho voluto indagare io vi invito a
prepararvi un tè a farvi dei biscotti e
a tenervi forte perché voi non
immaginare
neanche quanti colpi di scena questo
diario di un compratore di visual
[Musica]
allora la prima cosa che ho deciso di
fare era controllare nelle regole di
youtube se ci fosse scritto qualcosa
riguardo alle visual comprate da siti
esterni e c'è in una pagina del supporto
di google con tanto di triangolo giallo
con punto esclamativo all'interno c'è
scritto le visualizzazioni generate da
aziende servizi di terze parti non
verranno conteggiate ho presi in
considerazione su youtube e potrebbero
portare azioni disciplinari nei
confronti del tuo account
incluse la rimozione del video o la
sospensione dell'account
quindi questa dovrebbe essere la
risposta alla primissima domanda che è
venuta in mente a tutti quanti e legale
comprare visual su youtube da altri siti
in teoria no nel senso che tu puoi anche
farlo ma quello che succede poi sono
cazzi tuoi
ma questo ovviamente non mi ha fermato
per la scienza questo e altro quindi
sono andato a navigare sul web per
trovare tutti i siti italiani che
vendono visualizzazioni e oibo quanti ce
ne sono con una velocissima ricerca su
google ne ho trovati subito più o meno
una dozzina e ci sono due tipi di
visualizzazioni che si possono comprare
quelle con il botto che sono quelle più
facili e più economiche che arrivano
istantaneamente e quelle definite da
alcuni siti vere che però ci mettono
mesi ad arrivare ma non finisce qui
ovviamente perché tu da questi siti puoi
comprare le visual ma puoi comprare
anche commenti like e dislike e uno
potrebbe chiedersi perché dovrei
comprare dei dislike perché dovrei
essere così scemo da comprarmi dei
dislike perché dovresti comprarli a te
quando poi bombardare di dislike il vino
di un'altra persona o ed è certo perché
nella maggior parte di questi siti
tu devi soltanto mettere quello che vuoi
comprare e un link al video non c'è
scritto da nessuna parte che devi dire
di chi sia al video o confermare che sia
tu non basta che metti un link e per 30
euro puoi comprarti anche articoli su
blog giornali
online e volendo c'è questa opzione puoi
comprare questa cosa qui
se vuoi essere extra triste comunque in
questo primo giorno decidono di comprare
100.000 visual in un sito che non costa
così tanto come gli altri ma il tempo di
erogazione ed alle 10mila e 30mila
visual al giorno che è quello che mi
serve cioè risultati immediati il
secondo passo è ovviamente creare un
canale da zero perché non voglio casini
sui miei di canali e quindi vado su
google e creo di angela ricette semplici
e facili stesso uomo ovviamente io che
sono un cretino semplicemente perché
adesso vanno abbastanza ma volevo un
argomento che fosse abbastanza facile
infatti creò anche un video di ricette
la pizza fatta in casa le ricette di zia
angela e siccome non volevo far vedere
me dentro il video è uno di quei video
fatti con le scritte e lo sfondo
culinario con una musichetta free of
copyright su youtube
però questo video vi sarebbe servito per
testare la compravendita di visual
quindi non l'ho fatto proprio lineare ci
ho messo dentro sempre qualcosa di mio
[Musica]
e ho fatto questo
un po perché sono una persona malata da
un certo punto di vista ma anche perché
mi sono chiesto durante questo a questa
prima giornata ma i siti che comprano le
visual lo guarderanno il video magari
guardando lo dicono no non posso darti
viso al suo un video così mezzo
demoniaco mezz'ora quindi lasciamo
perdere la risposta è se ne sbattono i
[ __ ] quindi carico il video e vado a
comprare per 149,99 euro 100.000
visualizzazioni e basta così non mi
rimaneva altro che aspettare
aggiornamento del giorno dopo alle 9 0 3
minuti del mattino del 9 febbraio sono
arrivati alle prime visual sono pochine
sono 2.757 numero particolare devo dire
ma sono arrivate sono molto emozionato
non vedo l'ora per i prossimi giorni
alle prossime ore
spero non ci mettono tanto aggiornamento
delle dieci meno 10 sempre del 9
febbraio si sono aggiornate le virtual
adesso sono 9.719 bravi aggiornamento ho
fatto dieci minuti dopo quello
precedente quindi sono le 10 del mattino
sempre del 9 febbraio ho scoperto una
cosa andando nei nelle statistiche in
tempo reale
ho scoperto che le visualizzazioni non
solo 9.000 e rotte ma sono circa 22mila
quindi sono arrivate tutte di getto
nelle prime ore del mattino ma youtube
non le sta non riesce ancora ad
aggiornarle in tempo reale e questo
poteva creare un problema perché in un
canale dove appena creato dove non c'è
traffico di alcun tipo né commenti né mi
piace negli scritti avere tutte tutto
quel boom di visualizzazioni avrebbe
potuto portare all'attenzione di youtube
il problema sempre il 9 febbraio alle 15
e 15 è arrivato il primo commento quindi
vuol dire che
e finito da qualche parte nei correlati
e qualcuno l'ha aperto ea solo quasi
20.000 visualizzazioni quindi da questo
punto di vista funziona quindi un
obiettivo del comprare delle visual
potrebbe essere finire nei correlati
perché se è finito nei correlati bidu
vuol dire che queste visualizzazioni
youtube le ha contate effettivamente
contate tanto che qualcuno ha commentato
i video e lo ha anche visto il video è
vero che durava 20 secondi però
congratulazioni che cos'è quella cosa
che si vede alla fine del video e io
ovviamente non potevo dire asilo
correggo ho fatto il finto tonto e ho
risposto quale io non vedo nulla e la
risposta non ha tardato ad arrivare al
secondo 12 c'è una strana figura
segnalerò a youtube il video è tanti
auguri vai vai brola segnalare i video
youtube
voglio vedere quando ti rispondono ho
fatto un errore ho fatto un errore e mi
è stato rimosso il video e non credo mi
sia stato rimosso per le visual comprate
ma perché qualcuno appunto come vi avevo
fatto vedere ha segnalato il video per
il contenuto in mezzo alla ricetta che
effettivamente ci sta perché è una
ricetta quello alla guarda gente come
magari famiglie e bambini compresi
bambini sono una ricetta per la pizza
fatta in casa e si ritrova una roba
demoniaca porca di una [ __ ] lo so non
so cosa fare non so
e domenica 11 febbraio e sono in ufficio
sono da solo in tutta la struttura
perché domenica e sono le quattro di
pomeriggio
e perché non so cosa fare ma devo
trovare una soluzione perché
l'esperimento non può finire così
quindi cercherò non lo so non lo so sai
cosa faccio quasi quasi scrivo al sito e
gli chiedo se è possibile o avere parte
dei soldi indietro perché comunque 30
mila visualizzazioni sono arrivate
oppure le rimanenti 70.000 poterle
spostare in un altro video e
fortunatamente sono stati molto gentili
la risposta è stata no gli attacchi al
caso e dopo un attenta analisi sono
giunto alla conclusione che se vuoi che
siano 150 euro
spendiamo le anche di più per provare a
crearne un altro di video sempre un
video della pizza fatta in casa ha fatto
da zia angela però senza satana
all'interno a su giro compro 100.000
visual e 500 like dallo stesso sito di
prima ma dicendo di comprare per provare
anche 25 commenti da un altro sito però
ha tra l'altro una particolarità del
sito dove ho comprato i commenti
c'è una specie di mini gioco per
comprarli te li devi scrivere tutti e 25
tu oppure puoi pagare 15 euro in più
rispetto al prezzo dei commenti e gli
dici bene o male cosa vorresti farti
sentir dire e te li scrivono loro e
allora così mi sono tirato su le maniche
ho iniziato a scrivere 25 commenti
completamente a caso ma bene o male
inerenti al video carico il video compro
tutto e torno a casa io non mi posso
distrarre un attimo che qui sono
arrivate 26.000 visual alle 15 è 0 1 del
12 febbraio saremo a te 26.100 visual e
i primi due commenti che ho comprato c'è
un problema però
sono stranieri sono commenti stranieri
io non è che sono finito in tendenza in
russia è possibile commenti bus ci
stavano scervellando per capire perché
caso fossero arrivati commenti russi
vuoi vedere che dei 25 commenti arrivano
tipo da utenti russi fasulli e quindi
youtube e li traduce in automatico
dall'italiano al russo e quindi quelli
sono due commenti che ho comprato
no no oppure sotto il consiglio del mio
collega abbiamo provato a tradurre il
commento più votato sotto il video è il
commento che ho notato è questo tendenze
sul serio e 102 [ __ ] in navigazione
web dalle faq quello poi mi sa che l'ha
tradotto male quindi forse siamo
internet sia lui sia per davvero io
stavo scherzando è possibile che fossimo
arrivati in tendenza in russia andiamo a
controllare nelle tendenze russe e non
c'eravamo
ovviamente probabilmente c'è stato
qualche altro problema ma la giornata
non era ancora finita
nuovo aggiornamento delle 17 07 sempre
del 12 febbraio sono arrivati i commenti
sono arrivati commenti che ho comprato e
che sono arrivati tutti insieme troppo
strano però sono giustificati perché ho
32.000 visuale ai quei commenti ci
stanno bene effettivamente ci stanno
bene non che siano arrivati tutti nello
stesso minuto non sono ancora arrivati
tutti ma cinque tutti si tutti insieme e
in quel momento ho fatto una cosa che
forse non avrei dovuto fare ho detto
guarda un po questi commenti sono tutti
con avatar diversi tutti con il nome
verosimile perché io personalmente da
questi siti mi aspettavo utenti senza
avatar cycle avatar grigio base con
numeri e lettere maiuscole e minuscole
come come codici captcha
come utenti e ho fatto una cosa che non
avrei dovuto fare ne ho aperto uno
allora ovviamente questo canale non
aveva contenti però era iscritto a circa
una quarantina
il canale youtube allora ne apre un
altro è anche lui era iscritto ad una
quarantina di persone e il 90 per cento
dei canali era lo stesso apro il terzo
stessa cosa e allora mi è venuto in
mente
siccome dal sito da cui ho comprato i
commenti puoi anche comprarti gli
iscritti gli account che usano per
creare commenti falsi li usano anche per
creare iscritti falsi quindi io ho
beccato 40 persone che comprano iscritti
però appunto essendo solo tre canali
italiani pure piccolissimo detto non me
ne frega nulla di farlo vedere quindi
non me li faccio vedere però solo lì ma
sentire qua lariano aria che sta
diventando pesante l'aria di questo
video stato cielo
questa giornata il colpo di scena
aggiornamento del 13 febbraio alle 9 20
7 del mattino ho scoperto dove siamo
finiti in tendenza non è in russia ma è
uno dei paesi che parlano la lingua o
comunque una variante del russo che
l'ucraina siamo in tendenza in ucraina
in diciannovesima xix vecchio nel video
le ricette di piange la pizza veloce
fatta in casa
oh oh mio dio mio dio vi state chiedendo
come l'abbia scoperto per innanzitutto è
arrivato un altro commento che veniva
tradotto in pizza e deliziosa ma non per
le nostre tendenze quindi da lì ho detto
no non è possibile che sia una
coincidenza che un altro commento il
gusto parli delle tendenze
andiamo a vedere gli analytics del video
innanzitutto dall italia sono arrivate
soltanto 55 visual è sopra di me
ovviamente c'erano paesi come pakistan
filippine lettonia uzbekistan moldavia
in kirghizistan del kirghizistan
il kirghizistan è un aspro paese
dell'asia centrale che sorge lungo la
via della seta a perfetto perfetto qui è
un ottimo paese per fare delle visual
sulla pizza fatta in casa e al primo
posto con il 27 per cento di visual
totali del video c'è l'ucraina quindi
per tutti gli ucraini che stanno
guardando questo video vi baxter vita
slovo vedi tale scopo in definitiva è
possibile fingere di essere famosi ma
come nei film di shyamalan
mancano ancora i tuoi finali
questo 14 febbraio questo san valentino
alle 13 09
non ho fatto in tempo ad entrare in
ufficio che c'è stato un nuovo colpo di
scena
ero arrivato a circa 40.000 visual
quindi me ne mancavano altre 60mila per
arrivare a 100.000 e nasce oggi mi
ritrovo 8900 me ne hanno tolte
praticamente 32.000 un aborto 32.000
visual credo pulizia di youtube non son
sicuro non so come funzioni ma a quanto
pare sono stati sono state tolte queste
vi sono qui da un certo punto di vista
ottimo vuol dire che youtube controlla
queste cose qui
dall'altro ho perso altri soldi giusto
per curiosità sono andato a rileggermi
le faq del sito da cui ho comprato le
visuale proprio perché i nostri servizi
vengono erogati da account e persone
reali
il processo di promozione e totalmente
legale e 100 per cento sicuro
ed ovviamente il giorno dopo o guarda un
po il 25 commenti che ho comprato da un
altro sito sono spariti e così come
nella famosa puntata dios e dove set
saluta anna l'aeroporto piangendo come
un disperato
io con una lacrima chemisol che al viso
saluto i miei quasi 400 euro spesi per
fare questo tipo so che molti di voi
sono lì a strapparsi i capelli dicendo
ma perché stai dicendo queste cose
guarda che c'è gente che potrebbe farlo
adesso tu dicendo loreley fatto scoprire
o mio dio e adesso sono abbastanza
convinto che chi volesse comprare le
visual le ha già comprata e
probabilmente lungi da me dirvi che cosa
fare voi siete liberissimi di usare
questi siti qui i comprabili
visualizzazioni scritti eccetera e
abbiamo visto che è possibile comprarsi
visualizzazioni iscritti like commenti
addirittura è possibile fare quello che
posso dirvi da youtube e che nessuno è
mai diventato diciamo famoso per
mancanza di altri termini che nessuno è
mai diventato famoso comprando l'isola
nesso perché per quanto sito vi possa
dire questi sono utenti reali
interessati ai vostri video non è vero
c'è quel sito di cui vi ho parlato che
ci mette mesi per farvi arrivare viva
perché sai come funzionano le sue
visualizzazioni c'è proprio scritto
nelle informazioni del sito mettono il
vostro video dentro spazi pubblicitari
di applicazioni gratuite
quelle sono visual probabilmente
effettive perché sono avviso al del vino
che parte nella pubblicità del vostro
video che viene inserito di dentro ma
vigente che magari sta giocando a un
gioco di merda free to play dall'app
store e si vede partire all'improvviso
come pubblicità non il solito moto per
pulire per terra ma il vostro cazzo di
video per farvi un esempio voi creato
una torta e volete farla mangiare a più
persone possibili e allora voi prendete
una persona l'allegata e la sedia e
comunque
notevoli le piccate la torta in bocca
finché non diciamo che il buon a quello
non è un cattivo e utente che avete
forzato a mangiare la torta un utente
che avete forzato a guardare il vostro
video perché si potrebbe analizzare la
situazione e analizzare i tipi di
visualizzazione i tipi di like i tipi di
sito i tipi di provenienza delle
visualizzazioni
ma questo non è un documentario di
netflix
prendete il video per quello che è un
esperimento grazie mille per aver
seguito questo video ci vediamo alla
prossima
[Musica]